after two years of wrangling the budget
battles have come to an end with an
agreement for the eu's long-term budget
up to 2020 but some wouldn't let it go
without a fight
and those of course who call for new
owned resources are the same people who
consistently call for more europe as if
throwing money at the problem will
somehow solve it in total the eu will
have up to 960 billion euros to spend
over the next seven years it represents
a 3.5 percent decrease from the last
budget and the first reduction in the
eu's history helga trooper dubbed it a
budget of missed chances saying the
priorities for wide of the mark and size
matters it's not our
selfish interest the eu budget because
it's for the european citizens and
therefore it would have been the better
way to spend
more with other and more future oriented
priorities it was an opinion not shared
by all the parliament
that in fact
talked
about
the eu has agreed to spend less but more
wisely the common agricultural policy
will get the largest slice of the pie
with 380 billion euros regional policy
took the largest hit but still receives
325 billion euros the horizon 2020
program will have over 70 billion euros
at its disposal and the eu is hoping its
erasmus plus scheme will boost
employability for the young in exchange
for the budget cuts mep secured some
compromises a midterm review in 2016
meaning that if economic circumstances
change as the politicians may following
the european elections next year there
is room for maneuver they will also have
a working group to look into how the
budget can become self-sufficient
through its own resources and made sure
next year's payments will be met the man
who steered the report through
parliament feels it was the least worst
deal the alternative of this budget is
no budget it's not perfect again but
this is much better than live with
uncertainty now that the seven-year
budget has passed meps can get to work
on how best to spend it starting with a
vote on wednesday on next year's budget